Hi, I'm Nicola and I want to
talk to you about translating
your Shiny apps into
multiple languages.
Some of you might
be disappointed
because when I say multiple
languages in Shiny apps,
talking about spoken
language, not
programming languages today.
So, since I'm basically going
to spend a couple of minutes
telling you how annoying
it was to develop a Shiny
app in multiple
languages, I thought
I'd start by telling
you why it's actually
a worthwhile thing to do.
The vast majority of websites
and apps, not just Shiny apps,
are developed in English.
The problem with this is that
the vast majority of people
don't speak English.
Only around two in 11 people
actually speak English,
and that's a large
number of people
to automatically exclude from
interacting with your Shiny
app.
Language selectors
are becoming sort
of more commonplace in
traditional web development
and we want to make sure that
Shiny apps don't sort of get
left behind.
Having said that,
translating Shiny
apps into multiple languages is
not that straightforward to do.
So what I want to
talk about today
is some of the small
issues that cropped up
when we were developing a
bilingual Shiny app to present
public health data.
Translation affects every single
component of your Shiny app.
Simple UI elements suddenly
became reactive expressions
that relied on a user input.
There are a couple
of packages out there
that help you to automate
the translation process.
But what we found is that
those packages typically
only work for a few of the
most widely-spoken languages,
and that there are built
in dictionaries typically
didn't include domain
specific terms.
So when we were developing
our bilingual app,
we built the translation
capabilities directly
into the app itself.
And during the
development process,
there were a couple of
seemingly small problems
that suddenly became
much bigger problems.
And one of those
problems was what
we thought was easy:
ordering a factor for a bar chart.
So most of you have
probably come across the fact
that R in the absence
of other instructions
will automatically sort
your character factors
and your factors alphabetically.
However, this doesn't
always make sense.
So, in this example, here we
have age groups encoded as character strings
and we might want to sort
them from young to old,
because that's easier for a
user to interpret.
So for a single language,
this is really easy, right?
We just create a factor
and we explicitly
set the factor level.
And we got a nicely
ordered bar chart.
The problem is
that when we start
doing this with
multiple languages,
it is not quite so easy.
First of all, we can't rely
on this alphabetical ordering
at all anymore.
If we sort of factor
in one language and we
sort it in another.
Actually, they're still
in different orders now.
So we can't rely on
alphabetical ordering at all.
We also don't want to have
to manually specify factor
levels for all languages.
It's a little bit
annoying if you
have a few words
in two languages,
but if you have
hundreds or thousands
of words in multiple languages,
it is completely unmanageable.
So, to solve this problem for
our app, what we did was we
ended up using the default or
primary language for everything
related to data processing.
So in our case, we did
everything in English.
And we explicitly set these
factor levels in English only.
For our bar chart example,
what that meant was
essentially creating
three different functions.
One function to compute the
breakpoint for the x-axis.
Again, this is done in English
only based on our data set.
We then created
a second function
to compute the labels based
on the output from that breaks
function and from the
user's choice of language.
Essentially we
wanted to translate
as little as possible.
So I hope the last few
minutes have convinced you
that translating Shiny apps, although
it's not straightforward,
is a very useful and
worthwhile thing to do.
What we found our biggest lesson
was that when we were building,
this translation was
always the first problem
that we actually had
to think about if we
wanted to add something new.
But to keep our app
actually efficient,
it was always the last code to run.
So I hope this has been useful.
Find me on Twitter.